the tropics of South Asia are teeming
with wildlife of all kinds National
Geographic Explorer sandesh qader
travels to a magical setting in Sri
Lanka where different species of baby
monkeys learn to navigate life in a
complex community
I'm an incredible Paulaner over Sri
Lanka this place was once the ancient
capital of the island it was abandoned
by humans long ago but now it's home to
a bustling society of primates
I've come to see how the young of three
species of monkeys can thrive in this
one unusual habitat this little guy is
Paulo
he's a toque macaque a species found
only here in Sri Lanka I'm here with
Professor Wolfgang Peters he's been
studying toque macaques and knows them
better than anyone else in the world
looks like they're on a mission they're
on a mission to have a belly full of
breakfast yes that's what their mission
is this morning in macaque Society your
mother's place in the hierarchy
determines everything from what you eat
to who grooms your fur Paula's mother
was the lowest ranking female in the
group now he's an orphan at the very
bottom of the social order
well his peers are grooming and nursing
their moms and playing for Apollo's I
was foraging trying to find something to
eat are there any chances of him being
adopted by one of the females I'm not
really adopted but yeah the aunts will
sort of groom him yeah and he's got
protectors in here he's not alone while
the troop helps Paula find his way had
the other end of society these little
guys are doing just fine their mother
Jim oosa is the alpha female which means
they've got it made
his name is Jessie right yeah he's only
3 years old but he looks the size of a 4
year old and that's because he's got
privileged position in their society
here mm-hmm priority of access to
resources yeah that's how it goes a
monkey Society in this monkey Society
macaques are at the top taking first
dibs on any available fruits but they
can raise their young side by side with
these grey langurs
because the languorous can eat food that
the macaques cannot the langurs have
evolved a four chambered stomach filled
with bacteria that help them digest
leaves which means for these longer
babies the whole forest is on the menu
we have this overlap of species they
share the habitat they come into a bit
of
conflict but generally it's a harmonious
coexistence of these species in the same
habitat
[Music]
[Music]